there's a new GTA update out and it's
worth checking out Rockstar brings us
the high life update with plenty of
upper-class goodies as well as some
major game changers that will make life
in Los Santos better but before we step
out in public and see what's new in Los
Santos get a haircut and freshen up
because it's Miller time go ahead and
take a stroll down to your local rip off
posen beat and flip through 32 new suit
options take the time to be original or
let the pros take over and start with
the basic outfit looking good but now
you can look even better with a handful
of new actions let's see what we got
here thumbs up hey there good-looking
and it's a wind-up you're hot you're
totally hot yeah air thrust one hot air
thrust 20 what up anyone see that jazz
hands bring sarcasm to surrendering new
season this season and then there's doc
which I think it means like hey I'm
gonna poke your eye out other than those
you can't on to your enemies with slow
clap and facepalm but most importantly
you can now finally mine gold and GTA
online PES enough that let's take a look
at some of the new high-end real estate
that hit the market all of the
apartments in high life are roughly
around half a mil I went with the
downtown flat with this sweet living
room and big screen TV kitchen huge
bathroom walk-in closet king-size bed
for eye poking and the view well it
sucks Construction Yard you kidding me
good thing you can now have two
properties because this is both all new
properties have ten car garages and this
one clearly needs some filling thank God
the high life update brings us for new
vehicles such as the Dinka thrust
motorcycle Hundley SUV Mascaro sports
car and the insanely popular supercar
Pigott season Donal if those are too
pricey for you you can now purchase an
additional 10 vehicles from story mode
like the ocelot f 6 20 but you're better
off finding that
Street before you hit those streets stop
by any nation and check out the new
bullpup rifle it's got some solid damage
but lacks and accuracy so if you're
serious about it well by the grip and
scope add-ons to make up for it yet what
has really changed up firefights are the
body armor updates you can now purchase
and use more than one set of body armor
similar to what snacks do to your health
making it essentially harder to take
down other players who have armor ready
to go so what else is new well you got a
couple of new landraces with the newly
added vehicles and a handful of other
new contact missions but what this
update will really go down in history
for or its attempts to make los santos
less frustrating it's called mental
state and it's pretty great the stat
keeps track of your behavior and allows
other players to determine what kind of
player you are if you're a fan of
murdering and show no mercy your blip on
the radar will reflect just that the
rhetoric players blip is the more
caution you should use towards them it's
a great way to prepare yourself when you
see a player flying down a road in your
direction unfortunately killing
pedestrians do factor into your
psychotic state so keeping the red out
of your reticle means you need to be
some kind of star citizen there are
plenty of more bug fixes and additions
to this update but there's only so much
I can give you in a video check out
rockstars newswire for all of the
changes thanks for watching see you next
time
you